pour en débattre sur ce plateau françois
pour les métis journaliste et auteur du
break 6 est une chance point
d'interrogation c'est important de
préciser aux éditions hauteur du monde
bonsoir à vous françois pour les matisse
à ses côtés pierre lévy rédacteur en
chef de rupture bonsoir pierre lévy
merci d'être avec nous avec votre une en
exclusivité pour nous ce soir enfin
libre c'est ça c'est ça
voilà d'arrêt dans deux jours et nous
avons évidemment consacré une grande
place à cet événement tout à fait
historique cela un jour de fête pour
vous peut-être moins de l'autre côté
alors fait pour les progrès qu sitter
larmes pour les autres aujourd'hui
messieurs sait-on vraiment qui a raison
de pleurer et qui a raison de se réjouir
ce qu on le sait avec certitude françois
pour les métis
on ne sait pas encore quand je vois
d'ailleurs la une de votre journal
enfin libre je me pose des questions
parce que sont ils véritablement libre à
partir d'après-demain
je n'en suis pas persuadé pourquoi parce
que les enjeux vont être énormes pour la
difficulté elle commence après demain ll
y avait déjà une difficulté parce qu'il
y avait une confusion sur les
négociations de sortie
une fois qu'ils seront sortis c'est pas
fini les choses ne changent pas
véritablement pendant une année il va y
avoir des négociations pour savoir quel
type de rapport on va essayer d'imaginer
avec les britanniques
et là il ya un véritable pari est sale
c'est sur ce sujet là que je pense qui
est véritable inconnue avec bruce
johnson ne connaissant un peu je pense
qu'il est un peu imprévisible et il a
une option entre deux options qui sont
possibles et qui sont totalement
différentes et dont les conséquences
sont radicalement différentes soit une
option qui consiste à dire on est libre
donc on rompt tout ce qui nous unit
c'est à union européenne on change tout
la réglementation cette réglementation
tatillonne qui était insupportable et
serra on change nos liens commerciaux
on change tout ce qui nous unit
sur le plan réglementaire avec l'europe
et on le fait en faisant ça il peut le
faire mais il risque de se couper de
l'accès au marché unique
or une des conditions pour lequel le
brésil pourrait fonctionner c'est qu'il
conserve quand même un certain nombre d'
avantages et ses avantages c'est
notamment l'accès au marché unique et si
ils optent pour cette position dans
laquelle effectivement ils vont devoir
se plier sans y participer à la
discipline marché unique
c'est une autre configuration on est
dans deux configurations qui sont pas du
tout qu'ils veulent pas du tout dire les
mêmes choses sur le plan politique alors
je vous rejoindrai sur un point
effectivement l'histoire n'est pas finie
ça c'est vrai
acton quand même un événement de portée
historique pour la première fois un pays
de l'union européenne décide de la
quitter
alors ça n'a pas été sans mal il ya eu
des guérillas à la fois parlementaires
et de bruxelles qui a tout fait pour que
la secte ne laisse pas partir cette
percée de ce pays d'ici dans quelque
sorte
et finalement ce dont notre journal n'a
jamais douté à aucun moment nous n'avons
eu l'idée qu'il pouvait y avoir un doute
le brésil arrive c'est à dire que
politiquement et juridiquement la
l'union européenne perd en quelque sorte
le royaume uni alors là où vous avez
raison c'est sur le plan économique il
va y avoir encore prendre dans les mois
qui viennent des négociations
importantes pour déterminer le type de
relations à venir entre les deux parties
alors chaque partie explique qu'on peut
arriver à un accord mais en effet vous
avez raison il ya des choix pour ma part
je ne crois pas du tout que boris
johnson opte pour une solution qui
serait en quelque sorte un faubourg
existe c'est à dire on en sort mais en
réalité on continue à appliquer des
règles même si on n'est pas représenté
au sommet au sein des institutions tout
ce qu'il a jusqu'à présent dit effet a
été conforme à ce qu'il a annoncé à
savoir ombres ont de manière claire et
nette
petit paradoxe quand même cruel pour les
pour ceux qui souhaitaient rester dans
l'union européenne
à westminster pendant des mois et des
mois les députés pro union européenne
ont bloqué ont tout fait pour faire
capoter l'accord qui avait négocié
theresa may avec bruxelles
un accord qui était finalement beaucoup
plus mou où elle avait dû d'ailleurs
compte tenu de son manque de majorité à
faire concessions pour concessions mais
qui a quand même été bloqués et boris
johnson est arrivé en disant d'accord ou
pas d'accord de toute façon on va sortir
et en tapant en quelque sorte du poing
sur la table
il a obtenu un accord alors certes avec
des concessions sur l'irlande du nord
mais fondamentalement qui est beaucoup
plus net certains iraient beaucoup plus
dur que ce que les antilles break sitter
avait fait dérailler donc d'une certaine
manière quand vous posez des questions
j'en termine là dessus l'écouté
justement boris johnson à cette époque
alors justement terminé on écoutera on
va l'entendre
et d'ailleurs quand on m'écoute ce qui
dit maintenant vous verrez que il tient
ce qu'il dit et ça ne veut pas dire que
dans notre journal on est des partisans
absolue de boris johnson il faut
reconnaître les choses et donc qui peut
se réjouir et qui peut pleurer mais nous
nous considérons qu aussi bien au
royaume uni que dans le reste de
l'europe ceux qui peuvent se réjouir
c'est ce qu'ils considèrent que la
question du brésil s'était d'abord une
question politique
gardons-nous ou plutôt reconquerrons
nous la liberté de décider de notre
avenir politiquement ou pas à l'origine
c'était l'époque car on va l'entendre en
décembre dernier le premier ministre qui
promettait l'âge d'or je ne pense pas
qu'il soit avant ou invraisemblable de
dire qu'un nouvel âge d'or pour ce
royaume uni est maintenant à portée de
main
et malgré les moqueries malgré la
négativité malgré le scepticisme que
vous entendez de l'autre côté nous
travaillerons d'arrache-pied pour le
réaliser alors vous le disiez françois
paul et matisse tout reste à faire ça
peut tomber dans un camp comme dans
l'autre on entendait le chantre du fric
si tu suis assez lino françois acelino
tout à l'heure qui nous disaient mais
regardez boris johnson augmenter le smic
il va investir des milliards dans les
urgences et la question vous est posée
voyez avec quel argent parce que il faut
que les quasi soignants exactement mais
en tout cas il l'a fait il a déjà
augmenter le smic
c'est ce que ceux qui fantasment
peut-être sur les sorties des pays se
disent voilà on a les pieds les mains
liées par par l'union européenne
responsable de tous les maux qu est ce
que vous leur répondez vous
je crois qu'il suffit de voir la
complication énorme qu'a représenté la
sortie de la grande-bretagne de l'union
européenne et ses deux années de
négociations de d'allers retours qui
centre ne s'est pas toutes les
complications liées à la sortie pour
montrer que ça désespère et beaucoup de
candidats à la sortie beaucoup de pays
qui auraient pu être tentés
effectivement par suivre l'exemple de la
grande bretagne ont réfléchi à deux fois
et aujourd'hui vous ne voyez pas un seul
pays de l'union européenne qui a envie
pour l'instant ou même qu'ils
l'expriment même en france où des
certains part si je pense notamment à
droite envisager très nettement un freak
site
c'est parti là on n'en parle plus donc
aujourd'hui toutes ces complications
montre que sortir de l'union européenne
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué qu'il n'y
paraît et boris johnson n'a pas encore
dit ses véritables intentions
ça c'est une très grande incertitude en
particulier pour l'avenir de l'économie
britannique
qu'est ce que vous craignez le plus
pierre lévy le beurre et l'argent du
beurre
lee johnson qui a en tout cas
certainement cette ambition avec la
crémière réagir
serait nul hier ce que vous avez dit
d'abord sur le smic et leurs familles le
salaire minimum britannique et avec quel
argent c'est c'est le secteur privé donc
évidemment les chambres de commerce le
patronat a crié comme tous les patronats
du monde quand on les contraint à
augmenter les salaires que jamais ce
serait possible mais dans les faits que
ça se fera ça se fera
et l'économie britannique non seulement
le son de revente est ignoble de santé
non seulement ne sombrera pas mais les
tous les éléments parce qu'on vient
finalement vivre un tournant depuis plus
de trois ans il y a eu donc cette
guérilla qui a donné l'impression que
c'est un enfer donc nous on ne peut
sortir que le chaos et que au fond
toutes les catastrophes nous attendait
au coin de la rue et bien maintenant on
va voir et chaque jour qui passe sans
que le royaume uni ne sombre dans la
manche est un démenti cinglant à ceux
qui nous expliquait que ça allait être
un cataclysme
alors il faut quand même se rappeler
tout ce qu'on nous a expliqué tout ce
qu'on vous a annoncé tous les
cataclysmes je pense par exemple
monsieur mark carney qui était jusqu'à
peu le gouverneur de la banque
d'angleterre qui expliquait en 2016 ça
allait être une catastrophe absolue
aujourd'hui il est devenu responsable de
l'onu pour le climat ils annoncent
d'autres catastrophes
quoi qu'il en soit les cataclysmes en
question non seulement ne sont pas en
passe de se produire mais tous les
éléments tous les indicateurs tous les
indices qu'on connaît wihr plutôt au
vert que ça soit en matière de chômage
et donc d'emplois que ça soit en matière
d'investissements que ce soit en matière
de croissance et même de prévisions de
croissance le fmi qui faisait partie des
élites mondialisées qui prédisaient le
pire doit bien reconnaître que en effet
ce n'est pas exactement les catastrophes
annoncées et donc monsieur le juge cité
monsieur carmet disait alors qu'on lui
disait salle est une catastrophe est lié
le le mieux n'est pas encore assurée
est-ce qu'on a quand même le recul
nécessaire vous invite à écouter michel
barnier négociateur en chef pour qui
certains pans de l'industrie seront
confrontés à des retombées négatives et
il a plus il est très fier qu'il y aura
des conséquences négatives le camp
d'istres des finances s'agit de david a
reconnu la semaine dernière que certains
points de l'industrie seront confrontés
à des retombées négatives l'industrie où
il fait négative fallout quel que soit
l'accord que nous atteindrons son âtre
futures relations
le break tu seras toujours une opération
visant à limiter les dégâts
matelas match limitée chez de uk a
choisi tout le royaume uni a choisi de
devenir un pays tiers de quitter le
marché unique et l'union douanière de
laisser derrière lui le cadre de règles
communes de noeux et la surveillance
commune et la cour de justice comme
rouge comme une supply chain and common
corto justice 12 août ou qu'il a choisi
de créer deux espaces un commentaire
cela rend impossible à commerce sans
section une possible mc it is also même
tout bio brive exit et est aussi censé
avoir pour objectif une grande bretagne
mondiale mais pour nous qui franchement
ces lieux qui contribue à rendre les
états membres plus tourné vers le reste
du monde
monk lauper lévis on agite encore le
chiffon rouge c'est du bluff
alors quelques unes choses soient bien
claires dans notre journal nous n'avons
jamais affirmer ou analyser que la
réalisation du breakbeat allait
automatiquement et mécaniquement créer
un paradis sur terre simplement le
breakbeat et je les dis d'abord et avant
tout un enjeu politique c'est à dire que
les britanniques reconquiert la liberté
de décider de leur politique économique
bonne ou mauvaise avant elle ne pouvait
que dépendre de l'union européenne
aujourd'hui ils ont la liberté de
choisir c'est ça l'essentiel alors
maintenant effectivement il y à un
certain nombre de signes qui annoncent
qu'ils semblent indiquer que les
catastrophes annoncées ne sont pas
produites et ne sont pas en passe de se
mir je ne dis pas que c'est parce que le
brésil va créer des miracles simplement
tout ce qu'on nous avait expliqué
s'avèrent inexactes et donc on va voir
les choses mais encore une fois la
liberté d'un peuple de décider de son de
son sort c'est quand même l'essentiel au
centre est mais pas tout à fait vrai
dans la mesure où ces c'est pas une
véritable liberté qui l'ont reconquise
le royaume uni lorsqu'il était dans
l'union européenne faisait partie du lac
le plus grande une des deux plus grandes
puissances commerciales du monde
aujourd'hui le royaume uni va se trouver
seul à devoir renégocier une centaine
d'accords commerciaux séparément avec
l'ensemble des pays à se trouver dans
une position de très grande infériorité
lorsqu'il ne devra s'adresser par
exemple aux états unis par exemple à la
chine où son poids ne sera pas du tout
le même que lorsqu'il faisait partie
d'un ensemble beaucoup plus puissant qui
est l union européenne ça il ne mesure
pas encore deuxième chose que je note
des pans entiers de l'industrie sont
directement menacés je parle je pense à
l'industrie au tout automobile
je pense à airbus je pense l'ensemble
des secteurs qui vont voir probablement
des débuts de rapatriement sur le
continent de d'activité industrielle
donc il va y avoir énormément de
conséquence je pense aussi que en partie
les gens qui ont voté en faveur du bric
site et notamment ceux qui sont au
centre de l'angleterre vont devoir
réaliser que cette partie de
l'angleterre a bénéficié des aides
régionales absolument considérable que
pour l'instant le gouvernement
britannique n'a pas imaginé la manière
dont elles pourraient les compenser il
ya un certain nombre de conséquences qui
n'ont pas été mesuré donc c'est alors je
suis je ne prédis pas la catastrophe je
fais pas partie de ceux qui prédisent la
catastrophe je fais partie de ceux qui
disent qu'il y aura des conséquences
lourdes pour la grande bretagne
oui l esi pierre mais les conséquences
lourdes
encore une fois ça sera des conséquences
d'une politique qui pourrait être menée
et décider librement
il y à un point sur lequel je ne vous
suis pas c'est c'est l'idée au fond que
dans le monde dans lequel on vit
plus on est gros et puis sans violence
porte et qu'il faut avoir en quelque
sorte l'effet de taille pour peser en
quelque sorte ça c'est un discours qu'on
le connaît bien qui est aussi celui par
une critique à votre guerre c'est aussi
celui de monsieur barnier comprend bien
que monsieur barnier va pas dire c'est
formidable maintenant puisqu'il a tout
fait pendant trois ans pour rendre la
vie impossible l'asbr existe mais voilà
on est en excellente écoute et c'est pas
parce qu'on est gros et puissant qu'on
s'en sort mieux on regarde et je prends
un exemple plus le plus caricatural si
je puis dire la suisse chi chi chi un
certain type d'accords sectoriels avec
l'union européenne mais qui n'est en
aucune manière tributaire est contrainte
par des décisions politiques
on peut pas dire que la suisse est quand
même et soit une grande puissance
économique dans le monde
eh bien personne n'a entendu que la
suisse sombret avait une situation
catastrophique au contraire même s'il a
rien et paradisiaque
on peut penser qu'elle s'en sort plutôt
mieux personne n'est pas membre de
l'union européenne ne dira comme la
suisa héros et la norvège sont des pays
qui finalement ce proche suivent l'union
européenne suive les réglementations
européennes et le fait de simplement les
chiffres censés participer directement
fonds qui sont dans une situation qui va
très bien sûr ça que je pense très
raisonnablement que si boris johnson
suit la voie assez prévisible de rester
très proches venus en europe et dans la
foi dans la règlementation à la fois
dans les accords etc
il a plus de chance finalement de
maintenir à un certain niveau de
puissance économique de son pays que si
il choisit la rupture totale gens
manifestement bruxelles a l'air de lui
faire les yeux doux à l inverse les yeux
doux le président de la commission
européenne ursula von der leyen
juste avant ce vote un aujourd'hui voilà
avait une tonalité très douce heureuse
on ne vous aimera toujours on sera
jamais très loin on est patron d'ems
dans le temps d'un d'un divorce non
consenti un mais c'est à dire qui est
maintenant il ne peut plus faire
autrement il faut bien qu'elle fasse de
nécessité vertu ans avait dit oh là là
et ça sera le bric c'est dur les foudres
de vollard on leur avait prédit cela
quand même aux anglais c'est vrai on
leur avait prédit les pires catastrophes
s'il votait pour sortir de l'union
européenne là pendant trois ans tout a
été fait encore une fois je suis désolée
de me répéter mais on l'a vécu tout ce
mois après mois et quelquefois invité
sur ce plateau et à chaque fois il y
avait de nouveaux obstacles nouvelles
embûches qui résulte est pour
l'essentiel la volonté de bruxelles et
des antilles brixi d'autre part le
royaume-uni d' de faire capoter tout
cela c'était une illusion
donc les choses maintenant parce qu'on
le vip on n'est plus à une époque où
l'on pouvait comme ça s'est fait en
france comme ça s'est fait en irlande
comme ça s'est fait au danemark où on
pouvait inverser en quelque sorte le
verdict populaire parce qu'il faut quand
même rappeler ceux ci on parle économie
c'est normal qu'on réfléchisse sur les
concernent mais rappelons nous quand
même l'essentiel
si aujourd'hui la grande bretagne sort
de l'union européenne
c'est parce que son peuple en a décidé
ainsi en 2016 et c'est donc c'est le
respect du verdict démocratique tout à
fait et donc je sorte d'accord là dessus
et est donc mais c'est l'essentiel
après une fois créé cette nouvelle
situation l'union européenne a autant
intérêt à faire entre guillemets les
yeux doux au royaume-uni que l' inverse
contrairement à ce qu'elle dit est donc
je suis tout à fait convaincu qu'il y
aura sans une forme que personne d'aucun
en ait encore des relations maintenue
bien entendu n'y a pas une guerre
travers de la manche je vous rappelle
quand même qu'en général un accord
commercial sur trouver un véritable
accord spécial avec partie seulement en
général ces deux trois voire quatre ans
voilà en général là johnson a fait le
pari de le mettre sur une année mais il
arrivait au au 31 décembre de visée mais
regardez si jamais si jamais il n'y
arrive pas mais regardez retombe dans
l'hypothèse la praxis des trois mois il
a fallu trois ans pour une arrivée à se
sortir d'une situation inextricable
au moment où boris johnson arrive
il dit moi je vais régler la situation
en deux mois et de fait il a presque
parce que son parlement le parlement tel
qu il est l a contraint à le 10 août
donc ça il ya eu le temps de massy
solution le boris johnson a quasiment
tenu parole alors que personne je vous
rappelle que j'ai je me dis juste comme
une phrase mais il y avait eu un premier
accord signé j'en ai parlé entre theresa
may et bruxelles cet accord qui avait
été long à se délier et une fois signée
bruxelles les vingt-sept avaient dit il
n'est pas question qu'on y toucher une
seule virgule
c'est un ces signes essais signés on ne
fera aucune concession supplémentaire de
quelque nature que ce soit c'est
l'accord point bas et c'est ce que je
vous disais le temps le temps a changé
mais le ton a forcément changé sauf a
déclaré la guerre à la grande bretagne
donc chaque partie a intérêt à ce que
les relations non seulement commercial
mais de sécurité de défense de soi
évidemment soit à un état tiers pas
jouer des jeux dangereux
par exemple si boris johnson imagine
tout d'un coup de dire bon ça y est les
impôts on les descend en flèche ont fait
de la concurrence fiscale ont créé une
forme de singapour de européen mais je
me permets de vous interrompre sur
singapour c'est très drôle
je me suis fixé le développer quand même
pas de nom mais l'action de manger le
moment dépendant ou à s'affranchir d'un
minimum de règles de bon comportement de
relations commerciales effectivement là
on se met dans une position où on est
plus en recherche d'un accord où en est
votre position dans lesquels on devient
opposé opposants et donc dans ce cas là
effectivement ce bronze la véritable
question parce que je rappelle quand
même que pour le royaume-uni l'important
c'est de garder les avantages d'un accès
au marché européen
c'est ça qui est en cause excusez moi
j'étais un peu vif à vous at elle a dû
attendre la fin bien d'entendre un seul
mot singapour qui m'a fait réagir oui
absolument
ça me fait réagir c'est quelque chose
qu'on entend souvent le risque existe
dit on que boris johnson opte pour une
option singapour sur tamise alors qu'est
ce que ça veut dire le ring et arcade
une sorte de dumping fiscal social
environnement pas de tout ce qu'on
voudra et mais c'est très drôle parce
que
l'union européenne vient de signer un
accord commercial avec singapour
donc si c'était un modèle de
déréglementation on le saurait donc
prendre cet exemple en disant ça va être
singapour sur tamise de singapour en
réalité elle vient de signer avec
l'union européenne accorde un accord de
libre échange
donc moi je ne suis pas quelqu'un qui
pense que le libre échange et la panacée
qui va régler toutes les questions non
je n'en suis pas un fanatique mais ça
c'est donc nos analyses
chacun peut évidemment avoir sa propre
sa propre analyse
je ne crois pas du tout que boris
johnson va opter pour dire on a fait le
break site
mais on va continuer à appliquer les
mêmes règles et ce serait d'abord un
suicide politique tout simplement
et en plus je pense que la manière de le
dire nous on peut le faire sans nous qui
nous sommes
ah bah ça ne pourra échapper à personne
et ça ne pourra échapper à personne
d'autant que d'autant que l'union
européenne souhaiterait ça et donc ne
manquera pas ne manquerait pas de crier
évidemment victoire si en effet boris
johnson accepté de se mettre sous le
contrôle de la cour de justice
européenne par exemple pour régler les
différends ou d'accepter que les règles
en termes dé change de commerce de
réglementation divers et variés sa
lignée de manière dynamique en plus sur
celle de l'union européenne
ça serait non seulement un suicide
politique mais j'ai alors on discute et
un petit peu avant l'émission nous
sommes d'accord sur un point c'est boris
johnson est un homme qui est flexible
est un homme cet anneau canoniste
pragmatique si l'on veut avoir un gars
visible mais et je crois que c'est
également un homme qui a une vision à
long terme et les zincs l'intérêt de son
parti si je puis dire c'est d'être là où
on ne l'attend pas c'est à dire de faire
une politique qui n'est pas du tout
traditionnellement celle des tories par
exemple vous avez des routes une partie
des conservateurs vous avez eues il
vient par exemple de conflit ou une
compagnie privée d'aviation est
complètement et le telegraph analyser ça
comme une trahison du thatchérisme
en quelque sorte donc et il parle
d'investissements publics massifs
notamment en direction des régions
favorisées
s'il veut tenir tout ça il
trouver ou pire les guides cet argent
parce que c'est alors c'est ce que poser
des tas de questions je sais pas s'il va
le trouver là où je souhaiterais qu'il
le trouve personnellement je pense que
comme dans la plupart des pays de
l'union européenne les moyens financiers
existent pour peu que la production ne
bénéficient pas de manière déséquilibrée
au capital au détriment du travail mais
ça c'est une autre émission
voilà donc je pense qu'il n'y a pas de
souci sur le fait que les moyens
existent les prendre at il effectivement
la salle histoire de le dire a encore
une fois moi je ne suis pas un fanatique
de barry johnson j'essaye de comprendre
sa logique et je crois comprendre que
politiquement il souhaite ancrer son
parti dans des classes populaires qui
sont celles qui ont fait gagner le
breakbeat et qui ont fait gagner boris
johnson qui l'a piqué au labour et qu'
ils souhaitent en quelque sorte
conserver pour le parti tory le modèle
françois pour les motifs
moi je note simplement on a suivi la
séance du parlement européen cet après
midi que tout le monde personne n'a
remis en cause l'appartenance à l'europe
pas l'union européenne j'aime pas les
peuples alors aucun nous sommes
européens
nous sommes tout le monde a lui même
même un élevage
ce qui veut dire quelque part que
effectivement cette europe qui nous faut
avec laquelle nous fonctionnons dépasse
celle qui satisfaisante mais que
globalement l'ensemble des peuples
considère qu'ils sont partis pro
déclenché des scènes ensemble et les
politiques
l'ensemble des aînés de politique pas
des peuples merci merci messieurs
françois pour les métis à pierre lévy
d'avoir accepté le jeu du débat